hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the Greinke chess
classic is the penultimate round its
round eight and Peter Svidler with the
white pieces fair faces world champion
Magnus Carlsen now it's a very important
game not only for the standings in the
tournament and well for for playing good
chess but also if you've been a
subscriber on this channel or you just
know from general knowledge ever since
their game in 2013 in the Kansas
tournament when Peter Svidler defeated
Magnus Carlsen since then a Swedish had
opposed has a positive score against
Magnus Carlsen so it's a great
opportunity for Magnus to equalize the
score will he be able to do it he does
have the black pieces we'll just have to
wait and see and also we do have some
nice footage from the grantee chess
classic video team so let's just enjoy
that as well here we have a very nice
close-up of Magnus now and since we
since he shaved his beard we're also
using that one for for our profile photo
to the left as you can see also we have
some nice footage of of Peter Svidler
here and there you have it really really
focused on the position as as you should
be when you face the the World Chess
Champion so let's just enjoy that for a
brief moment and also here we have some
nice footage again a spoiler pondering
and the position and in the back you can
see for the moment blurry Carlson
checking up the game between Maxima
sherrilyn Grove and young Vincent Kaymer
and you can see Vincent giving Maxime
the stairs he can't help himself but you
know that's this is just how it is so
that's was the footage I do hope you
enjoyed that now let's check out the
game twitter has the white pieces and he
opens with E 4 which means if you opened
with e4 against cost and more most
likely you will get C 5 and you better
be ready for his World Chess
Championship preparation
but after Knight f3 and the knight c6
whittler didn't go for d4 he went for
the closest Ilya Knight to c6 and ok
with E 5 by Carlsen Bishop to c4 by
Svidler Bishop to e7 and now d3 we have
D 6 and night to d2 s wiggler now starts
rhe maneuvering this night he wants to
go all the way to f1 and then perhaps
III orgy three nights to have six by
Carlson he's not ready to Castle we have
Knights to f1 Knights the d7 khasinau
wants the castle taking a church to get
out of this nasty diagonal and of course
Bush at five cents fiddler is taking so
much time
Tory maneuver his knights to better
squares in the opening we have Knights
the d5 by cellular and now comes Knight
the b6 and here just Knight captures we
have Punk after Sun b6 getting us from
semi-open file for the rook and c3 now
taking away the b4 end d4 square from
Carlson's night with castles Michaelson
now comes finally nice to e3 and Bishop
to g5 now we have castles by sweedler
and first King to h8 khasinau wants to
push f5 and it's interesting in 2001 in
the feed a World Chess Championship
knockout Vishwanathan Anand had this
position against a vastly von Schuch and
if one should also played this King to
h8 maneuver but in that game Bishop d2
was played and eventual won that game
against Anand but here's Riddler goes
for a three and it's a new move in this
position so it's now as a move 13 that
we have a completely new game on our
hands
so Crossin Percy's wood is plan with f5
Knight captures on f5
first a trade of dark square Bishop
Bishop Bishop captures NF C one route
captors on c1 and now Bishop captures on
f5 we have a captures on f5 and now not
recapturing immediately but first you
want to get that sweet d5 moving it's
it's the dream of any Sicilian player
you know if you're able to go d5 then
everything will be alright so d5 first
forcing Silver's Bishop to go back rush
up to a2 and now finally recapturing
route captures on f5 Queen to g4 now
pressuring the rock but just rook to f6
it's a very nice dark square so you
don't have to worry about anything bad
happening to the rook and here sailor
goes for f4 seems like a temporary pawn
sacrifice but it's not not all that
clear what white gave gains in return
but it's not all that easy to find a
better move maybe just getting the rook
to
better square and waiting for person to
make a move but here across and just
captures it and you are not able to
recapture if you recapture then you get
ninety five attacks the Queen and the D
three pawn and after you move the Queen
back to just rook captures captures and
captures here will win you the game for
black so after it captures on f4 Queen
g5 not allowing ninety-five to come with
an attack on the Queen and our cousin
says okay I'm just gonna defend my f4
pawn I'm gonna give the d5 pawn away so
sweedler wins back the pawn and then
I'll just work the d8 forcing his Queen
back Queen to f3 and now Knight to e5
forcing the Queen to move yet again we
have Queen to e4 and now Knight to g4 so
you can see that the Queen and route
battery are keeping an eye on the f4
pawn and now crossing plans to bring
this Knight over to e3 which will pretty
much number any influence as wielders
rook rooks have rooks e2 e1 by Sevilla
and now just Knights the e3 so now the
pawn in the night are completely
blocking or Silver's rooks we have rook
to F 2 as the rook was attacked on f1
and now comes Luke th attacking the
Queen Queen captures on b7 and now that
the Queen finally left the scene g5 by
Carlsen and here you can see that the
material on the board is pretty much
equal silver is up upon but it's not
really a pawn that matters what's
important is that Constance rooks are
much more active and his knight is a
much better piece than Spillers Bishop
here I mean it's a beautiful diagonal
but it's not really doing all that much
here whereas cross tonight here is
really keeping control of the board and
here again it's hard to fight a move
across and wants to play g4 you could
block it let's say h3 but then just h v
hg 4 is coming either way so silver
tried a different plan he went rook F to
e 2 seemingly baiting g4 across and said
okay I'm gonna go g4 either way and now
he just retreated with the rook rook to
f2 we have Queen to h6 now if pawns
start marching forward the Queen will be
protecting the night here and also if g3
then Queen to h2 will immediately be a
threat
Queen to c7 and the now comes rook to f8
just again putting a lot of pressure
across the F file with and g3 is coming
there's really not all that much you can
do here swittel played h3 and now just G
captures on h3 and here g3 again not not
not a lot of resistance but there there
was no better move F captures on g3 by
Carlson and now comes Luke captures on
f6 crossings Queen is under attack but
it doesn't matter all that much because
black has a decisive attack so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the winning idea for black I'll give you
a couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent
checkmater in two and you have
definitely gone for the head and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
here Carlson played h2 wit check the
kink has nowhere to go
the knight the guards the g2 square and
the F 1 square so the King has to go to
H 1 and here Carlsen just played g2 and
this is now checkmate the night it
controls the pawn here the Queen
protects this point and it's very rare
to see Chuck made between our 28 and 27
hundred grand master but there it is 33
moves I mean in this day and age I mean
even this can be considered the
miniature so it's a really really a
delightful game I don't know when will
be the next time when we will see such
such a treat Sam Smith loses cross and
wins yet again getting his a rating
performance to I believe almost 3000 I
don't know I think with the white pieces
he has a 3,000 performance with the
black pieces maybe 2900 and almost 3,000
so it's really really just insane what
he's doing and I'm not sure but I think
he actually already won the green key
just classic even one run before facing
Maxime hologram in the last last round
as he does have six and a half points
only one that can catch up to him I
believe it's Fabiana Caruana and even if
he wins the tomorrow's game in Causton
loses then both of them will have six
and a half but I think crossing has some
better
additional criteria I will check on that
and get back to you as we will be
definitely showing another game from
this round and then we're gonna talk a
bit more about the standings and here
finally there you have it if you
consider classical games
Magnus cross and tied Peter Svidler 2 to
2 sorry I have no idea why this is so
large let me just get that a bit ok I
did have it crossing tied Peter Svidler
2 to 2 with 15 draws and okay including
rapid exhibition games cross and beat
Svidler 14 to 7 with 25 draws but it
took cross and whole whole six years but
finally after 2013 he equalized his
score against Peter Svidler so the next
time the two of them face each other it
will be who will again be able to take
the lead but yeah really an insane game
and it's really amazing how Crossing can
keep winning game by game by game and he
started the tournament by winning two
games with the black pieces so that's
also really really cool and but it's
something I think it's a it's not a
trend but it it seems that today it's
pretty much the same if you play with
the white pieces or with the black
pieces I mean to these top grandmasters
it's it's pretty much all the same and
one other thing I really find
interesting is Carlsen really started
this tournament with two wins with the
black pieces and he continued playing
excellent chess and then as you all know
a lot of players a lot of people say
that chess players are very
superstitious and as you know Carlson
started this tournament with a beard and
it was a pretty big beard and then in
the middle of the tournament he shaved
his beard and as you know you know chess
players are superstitious you might
think okay I'm playing good chess with a
beard I'm not gonna be sharing my beard
but Carson did and he still continues to
play excellent chess so there's one I
mean one example of a chess player
obviously not superstitious but yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank urethane aniket
Modi Aditya Hardy Karan Viveiros nuke
and me how both shares for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous video see
her think all for watching and I
soon with some more content from the
Greg HS classic sir
do check out the links in the
description below if you want to check
out the 2013 game between a sailor and
Carlsen from the candidates tournament
also impressions from the previous round
and maybe some interesting interview if
I if I managed to find it I will also
put it in the description below so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Sunday